all right taika
do you know what we're about to do
yes we're about to fly
isn't that crazy
do you know what that means
nice are you ready to find out
yeah
and we got scaredy cat silent mikey
[Music]
how did you hit all the wrong notes no
it was perfect
you avoided the entire melody from the
back and i just got my c major in my
head yeah it's completely all the way
tiger do you know where we are
we're in
indoor skydiving
your window
oh it's down you gotta roll it back up
dude no it's too high
it's too high yeah
uh-oh how do i do it
there's a button
it's a button little dude
this dude will never experience
rolling a window up i know right
rolling a window up doesn't make sense i
know never roll the window down
[Laughter]
yeah dude
all right little dude your turn go
monkey stand on there hey put your
shorts up
you said take off your shoulders no no
no no no stand on the silver thing you
got to weigh you don't lean on the wall
though because i got to make sure you're
right you're the right uh weight okay
thank you what is he like 40 44. oh nice
good job
tiger are you ready to fly
okay ooh that's fun
it doesn't be so fun
thank you for following the rules but
we're going to go up there and take a
look first and see what we're never
following the rules yeah
dude i always follow the rules no dude
no camera attacker i know now i want to
go up there because they said we can't
bring this camera in so i am going to
get the video from their inside camera
but they said no camera because it's a
wind tunnel so whatever gets sucked in
will get chopped up and spit back out
oh yeah observation gallery
so i do want to see whoa it's cold in
here
it's cold freezing that's crazy why is
that just the wind i don't know
it's cold in here i'm lucky
all right let's take a look oh there it
is that's a big old
big old tunnel
are you scared mike
no
you sure no way dude i was born to fly
look at me how are you
this is a very aerodynamic physique
tycho you ready to have some fun
you can be flying around
with mama and papa
let's take a look over here on this side
oh that's crazy there's a straight up
fan right there
there's a big old fan i like that it's
padded everywhere too
that's pretty cool that's what my
doctor's office looks like you know what
my doctor's office adopted
let's go back down let's go find mama
we just checked out the wind tunnel i
don't want you away from me i don't know
where you were at no [ __ ] and that's why
i said wait okay let's go no
yes take a look please no not that way
this way
yeah come on baby
show mama where to look monkey
crazy are you nervous no not at all yeah
no
pokemon rollercoasters recently been
nervous on roller coasters and stuff no
i have it yeah i will be would be drunk
even if i drove a little bit faster well
i'm kind of scared are you talking about
roller coasters are driving because you
can't drive for [ __ ] so of course i'm
going to be nervous what about roller
coasters no i'd love roller coasters
what about was going to go off-roading
you said you got scared about yes
because you
it's really cold in here
[Music]
uh
[Music]
how was the mama was it fun it was super
fun i think the coolest thing was
watching this dude do it not once but
twice
uh it was rad because i thought like the
first one i think as soon as we walked
in i was like oh man he's gonna be so
scared yeah because that wind tunnel is
loud yeah powerful but he was chilling
and he got it on it twice so i think
that was the coolest for me to witness
i'm so proud of you monkey dude
good job dude
how about you scaredy cat michael
dude
me and taco are chilling that's awesome
did you have fun dude
that was you
that was you dude did you have fun
monkey
yeah you were superman that was you
that's what you were doing tiger did you
feel like superman in there yeah did you
see that you were flying
standing
hey look at a little guy over there good
job the first time is 85 because that's
awesome
the first time is class yes and after
that it's 45 40.
all right so we're this is a video of us
just finishing look at taika
he's getting ready to go
kids fly every day
oh i think they're going to fix his
goggle first there's a photo okay
they're going to fix his goggles
and then he's going to go and fly super
fun activity all right
oh they stopped it because we were
recording
that was him
all right so we're in this plaza now
this plaza reminds me of the 626 san
gabriel valley
like crazy yeah
if we did if it wasn't vegas over there
i could literally see the real hotel and
even that building over there
yup look at this
crab and spice which is the vegas
version of boiling gravel yeah i'm gonna
have to go around okay yeah so we're
getting a bit of seaweed yeah all the
85 degrees look
dude is this 66
in vegas or what
all right so this place is called
shanghai
tell me about shanghai plaza monkey tell
them tell a monkey
yeah but they got all these stores a
barbecue chicken spot
a
noodle spot if we don't crash
if we could just you know because that
car was about to take it damn asian
driver
who's worse mexican drivers are in the
asian drivers
oh my goodness
how do you crash the automatic car
what are you talking about just kidding
you know
that teal is really funny he said he
said you can't vlog me you gotta vlog
him all right then tell me tell me
something about your life
i i wasn't playing with superheroes and
cards do you play superhero cards yeah
okay what about a boom sucker like a dd
yep i want that
so we're just out here getting some ice
cream
ice cream
i love getting korean shaved ice hey go
inside don't walk on the parking lot
like a papa
um what i love about getting korean
shaved ice is there's a lot of shaved
ice a lot of the
uh lack of calories is just ice and you
get to mix the ice with the ice cream so
it's actually a
great filling dessert with less calories
we're going to be going here
salt and beans
so my favorite flavor is black sesame
but i think most people voted on a fruit
and we got strawberry last time i don't
know why but i didn't really like it so
i ended up getting mango but here are
all the flavors that you got earl grey
which i love you got the original which
is probably my favorite too i like the
grandma flavors
chocolate man a big fan mainly i think i
love the green tea like earl grey pink
and the black sesame but we got mango
this time
oh snap happy boy
happy boy
mango
with extra condensed milk it looks
cheesy yeah those cheeses i was gonna
say these look a little sucks
these look a little sucks
there you go
yeah you're all kind sir thank you thank
you my friend gentlemen right there
justify it
let me know how it is wait i think
that's already a lot of juice
oh although we're trying to make content
out here
i'm trying to get some views
you got to eat
you don't want ice cream
okay you don't have to eat ice cream
okay this guy is crazy
[Music]
so
this is really good
have you had this before korean vice i
think so not mango there's usually a ice
cream at the bottom too i normally go um
like chocolatey things
it's not chocolatey at all yeah what are
you talking about this guy's crazy
what part of this is chocolate i don't
understand what you're saying you said
have you eaten something like this i
said yes i have but i typically go
chocolatey things that 100 made sense i
thought you said you typically don't own
chocolate no i do
it's very good fresh mango
nice and juicy like i like it oh another
angle ice cream at the bottom there go
down to the bottom
look at the bottom i think mango is my
favorite fruit
really now that wow i don't need a
little ice cream with some
shaved ice a little bit of condensed
milk up here
what's your favorite fruit
mango's pretty good i love peaches
pizzas are good peaches you never eat
peaches no one buys it for me i'm not oh
no no one buys it for my mans
your mom buys it from that's why i love
her
[Music]
oh these are the ones i only get in
japan which ones these are my favorite
oh don't you get something here oh i
have a ton oh you do yeah these are
really good
well this
like these two are the ones that they
don't sell are they better than burt's
bees oh yeah really hundreds i'm gonna
get some of this too
what's the flavors damn i wish i could
look at the chocolate
matcha oh this one's
uh
welcome good luck this is tokyo
lifestyle store oh cute that's one thing
that's cool about the asian language if
you go with kanji it unites japanese
chinese and korean like the old school
korean writing is actually chinese oh
yeah so it's cool that i can read that
because i speak chinese super cool
so this plaza is pretty cool i'm
definitely going to come back when i'm
hungry one day
they got like a thai restaurant
the banana leaf is malaysian
which is so rare to find malaysian food
anywhere at least especially in the san
gabriel valley but there's actual
malaysian food and i loved it ever since
i've been to malaysia
and they got like a korean bbq chicken
spot
we got all kinds of random food and then
a
japanese spot over there next to vape
man
lots of good yummy food so if you guys
are
um out here in vegas make sure to check
out shanghai plaza if you don't know
what to eat you just want to walk around
and shop around and see
what's on the menu what's poppin but
here's the malaysian restaurant and look
at this
barbecue sauce and i ate them up a
chicken nugget your size
yeah that was too small no dude i ate
the whole thing look at him he's fat
monkey hey
hey you where'd you look at my belly i
saw you look at my belly does it have a
big belly
my mom gave me every dollar she gave you
mcdonald's yeah every day every day
i don't care no i don't monkey tell the
truth that's not very good nutrition
that's not good nutrition at all
mama should probably buy um some 20
nuggets huh
you're going to kick my seat yeah look
what i do don't get kissed be nice
[Music]
okay so who's the funniest in the card
number one number one funniest is
pekka okay number two funniest is
and then who's boring
hey what did i do
that's not fair
papa's boring
what about mama no
no no just a very good taxi driver
no the taxi driver
yeah all right we're just cruising
around vegas
we're in this area of vegas called uh
desert shores which is also next to the
lakes and it's one of the
few places in vegas where they build
communities around
man-made lakes and it's actually a trip
because we think vegas you think desert
and dry but they did such a good job of
building these lakes out it really feels
like it belongs here and since we're
showing mike around
and white people love lakes we had to
show him the lake so that he feels at
home he's not white what is he i don't
know but anytime we quiz him on white
stuff he fails miserably i don't like i
don't like dip everything in ranch
that's a wife did not even know that i
don't even know that kind of way yeah i
didn't even know that's the best you
know that's a white thing or a
mayonnaise they'd be putting makeup on
the test
look at that well that's sick that's
sick right can you roll down a little
bit
venice
yeah i know right you don't swim in it
that's sick
some people's backyards have like little
uh ports yeah that's sick
that's really cool
do you swim in it i don't know about
that
i wouldn't
but it's beautiful
all right this is pretty cuny
so we have our halloween setup
all nice got the tombstone ready
got the lights on the tombstone so at
night it glows
we've got our scary kitty cat that is
feeding him flowers
we've got a skeleton
and whoever comes to our house is in
luck
oh my god
mopper hooked these the help should i
take it out
this is like one of those elementary
school earthquake kits should i make it
less
no
this is hook this is like ten dollars
worth of candy per bag no it's not holy
okay i'll make it less you are gangster
nah everyone will be happy oh
what the
dude
whoever comes to our house
lucked out because damn
you know how much you know how many
houses you usually have to hit up to get
this much candy
at least like 15 houses i don't know
i've never done this before well should
i take it out no no we're ready rock and
roll
happy halloween spider
all right came back home took a shower
in full
relaxation mode now but taika had a
really successful
trick-or-treat session i'm trying to
look for his candy
because supposed to be
in here no it's not in there where is it
look at this a full
bucket's worth he was so
dang happy did you see how they're
really successful yeah
that is not successful four-year-old
no did you not dude i remember going on
my block and we grew up poor so we
always had a pillowcase pillowcase
uh and my pillowcase you know how big
those things are it's like this yeah
half of it would be full but you said
yeah you also want like the whole
neighborhood we only went like a couple
streets
that's good yeah that's a good point
i'll give it to you
so yeah super successful
tucker's getting ready for bed now so so
am i
and uh i'm sure there's no doubt right
here just to tighten around
anything oh one more left how cute
i was wrong but i will see you guys
tomorrow good night and have a great
start of the fall